pour limiter la pénurie alimentaire
justement la solution semble simple il
suffit de produire plus mais est ce
vraiment possible dans un pays comme la
france par exemple et cela tout en
respectant l'environnement
on sait que jusqu alors l'agriculture
intensive a rarement fait bon ménage
avec l'écologie laurence de chef
frédéric faure donc vous voyez
aujourd'hui cette parcelle de blé était
il ya deux ans je cher et nous l'avons
remis en culture comme d'autres
parcelles puisque nous avons remis à peu
près sûr nous avions 12 % de jachère
aujourd'hui on le fait dans les trois ou
quatre pour cent avec l'augmentation des
prix des céréales cet agriculteur de
picardie comme beaucoup d'autres
cultivent cette année plus de terre
entre 600 et 800 mille hectares
supplémentaires
la production française devrait croître
mais peut-on en france augmenter encore
les rendements bien sûr qu'on est
capable de produire plus mais sous
réserve effectivement qu'on nous laisse
nos moyens de soins aux cultures et de
protection parce que si on continue à
nous enlever tous nos moyens et les
produits qui nous permettent de soigner
nos plantes
évidemment qu'on ne pourra pas car
utiliser moins de pesticides et moins
d'engrais fait partie des objectifs
écologiques du grenelle de
l'environnement
impossible donc de produire plus selon
d'autres agriculteurs avec 80 quintaux à
l'hectare les français détiennent déjà
le record de productivité et les courbes
de rendement année après année montre
qu'actuellement ce gain de rendement par
hectare n'est plus possible
produire plus mais produire durable
l'objectif d'atteindre 20% d'agriculture
biologique en france
n'est-il pas alors contradictoires les
rendements de l'agriculture biologique
sont inférieurs aux rendements de
l'agriculture conventionnelle
je ne parle pas de la marge à l'hectare
je ne parle pas du revenu de
l'agriculteur je parle du rendement
physique mais comme je vous le disais
dans notre pays on n'a pas de problème
de quantité globale
aujourd'hui on peut remettre en culture
si les niveaux de prix sont bons et si
la demande est là on a des capacités à
produire plus car soixante mille
hectares sont abandonnés chaque année
par l'agriculture au profit de la forêt
la france n'apportera pas la solution
pour nourrir la planète mais l'afrique
les pays de l'est la russie ou encore
une partie de l'amérique du sud
de grandes capacités il y aurait dans le
monde un potentiel de 2 milliards
d'hectares cultivables